[Music]
Edward Kiran thank you H very very much
for joining me um startup Nation United
um you know difficult times for all of
us it's November 2nd at the time of
recording um you know we're about three
weeks H into um after the massacre and
and and the war global war on terrorism
and and and human dignity and um you
mentioned you shared with me that your
sons are heavily involved in in the war
and so we're all um praying so I
appreciate out of your busy schedule and
I know how involved you are with
everything that's going on in in a few
different aspects we're going to be
talking about technology we'll be
talking about communication and and
we're going to be talking about social
impact these are all critical aspects of
what's happening and and so thank you
again for being here I I'd love to start
start by hearing a little bit about who
you are what are you doing the daytoday
outside of the war and the conflict you
know who who are you and and what is
your daytoday in
general thank you Michael for hting me
uh I mean I I'm I'm managing a venture
capital fund called Catalyst and I have
established 30 years ago an investment
bank which is today the largest
Investment Banking team in Israel and
we're raising money for technology
companies uh uh and we fund the
technology companies for now more than
30 years we've raised about10 billion
for very companies over the
years amazing and if we look at October
7th October 7th 6:30 a.m. where were you
what was going on in your world during
that
time I I was actually seeing my family
in Paris I uh it was uh a tough moment
for me I came back to Israel I have as
you mentioned two boys that are serving
in the Army one is a officer in Commando
units and one was called for his miluim
and they are both currently serving in
Gaza actually the younger one had to see
a terrible horrifying attack of the
Hamas as he was fighting on October 7th
wow what was going on in your space in
your mind the days following October 7
how how did you find yourself integrate
into the collective effort um over the
days following the massacre and because
I was in Paris I I was invited because I
I was spokesperson of the army for many
years and I was also officer in a unit
which was handling negotiation in crisis
situation and hostage situation for more
than 10 years so I was invited in
different friends European media to
describe the situation so I really start
to present Israel position and uh
describing the uh What uh what Israel
was facing and uh explaining what is
theas all about and the need for uh
deployment of the
Israeli IDF to destroy the Hamas L was
mostly
communication with different media from
Europe but also in the US I had the
opportunity also to speak in Fox News
and other media in the US so that was my
initial
activities um I had also uh the need to
support one of the uh nonprofit
organization that have been been on the
board of for more than 20 years an
organization called SEL which is hosting
since 1982 volunteers from all over the
world and are working in different
military bases doing mostly Logistics
work uh when the war started we had
overwhelming demand from Jews and not
not only Jews from people from all over
the world to come to Israel and to work
in military bases one of the challenges
we faced at SEL is that typically we
have hosted more than 200,000 people
over the years since the establishment
of SEL but in in this case uh we have an
issue of Bally these volunteers were
sleeping in the military bases for
security reason it was not possible this
time so we had to find we still need to
get some funding in order to be able to
Lodge uh those Volunteers in hotel and
other places during that war so that
those were my two uh two core activities
since the war started
and obviously as a organization is
composed of partners that are very
sinist most of the Partners came and
immigrated from overseas so everyone in
our among the key people in the
organization have been active promoting
Israel in different ways and different
nonprofit
organizations incredible going back to
the to to your work and
Communications um in the days following
the massacre what what was that what has
that experience been like for you
representing Israel um in different
countries in different um populations
what what have you observed and what was
it like for you
personally you know I must say that uh
the uh media uh were had a
very uh they were very uh uh concerned
about the situation about Israel and uh
I've been communicating with media in
Europe mostly as a spokesperson and I've
never seen such a warm welcome from the
different
media it is obviously the horrific
images that we've seen have affected
everyone and uh I think that everyone is
also concerned about even in Europe
about the Islamic Jihad about the Isis
because they really understood that the
Hamas has the same attitude as Isis and
we saw that many of the French people
were affected by the attack in the batac
clan so obviously they they uh
were very supportive of uh situation and
Israeli efforts yeah you know if we if
if you're looking in the your your
general perspective on communication
during this time perhaps shine shine
some light for us uh with less
experience in in the communication
sector what what are we seeing and what
are some of the key elements that that
there needs to be an emphasis on not not
not the content necessarily of the war
but but in general strategically
thinking what is you know where are we
in communication with the world world
global perception and and what what is
our
role um as strategic thinkers and
communicators um during these times of
conflict I mean at least in the
beginning the media was very supportive
now they are facing a lot of
demonstration especially in Europe
because the Muslim population is very
strong especially in France uh even in
England but because the political
leaders understand what we're facing and
they have been showing their support to
Israel the core media also have been
showing still their support there is a
challenge today in Europe because there
big demonstration and there is very much
there is more and more anti-semitic act
my father was the head of the Jewish
community and and we uh we saw uh how
much hatred there is uh among the people
in the
Islamic Jihad that are
supporting uh among the Muslim that are
supporting the Islamic Jihad or theas
how much uh it is difficult and
challenging for the Jewish community
that has been exposed to anti-semitic
attack especially since the war started
one of the things we talked about before
um before starting this this recording
you talked a little bit about on the
technology side that also as a VC Army
you are you see a you invest in
technology companies you're seeing how
Technologies are relevant in this space
so I'd love to hear a little bit about
you know some of the technologies that
you see from the private sector and
their impact potentially on these types
of conflicts I mean we have been seeing
a lot of Technology over the years uh
many of the technology that have been uh
developed in Israel uh the the team was
training the Army and many of them came
from a special unit like 81 unit or 8200
unit we see that they have mostly used
the experience that they have gained in
the Army to develop technology that has
an impact on an
industry uh that benefit benefiting a
community and we've seen that in many
ways but we have also seen private
sector sometime developing technology
that have
an impact uh for the military industry
for example uh our investment bank has
been working with a firm called civan
laser which is a new Laser Technology
super powerful laser that enabled to uh
be complementary to the Iron Dome but
the main difference is that uh using a
laser enables to react at the speed of
the light so uh in real time and also
the cost of using the laser is just the
cost of energy so it cost about $2 $2
and a half doll each time you use it as
opposed to the iron doome solution which
cost for each rocket we're using or
missile we're using to destroy rocket it
cost between $50,000 to
$100,000 I think this is a solution for
the future um I think that when U Biden
Biden came two years ago in Israel it
was uh the the time uh G that was the
minister of defense and showed the
solution of cang to bid them during his
visit so this is something that is
disruptive and could change could be a
game changer in the way the Israeli
Defense Force can protect themselves
from attack from
missiles I may also uh show you another
example about how the technology coming
from the military can be use can have an
impact on society we we were at Catalyst
the only Venture fund that invested in
Mobil you're probably familiar with
Mobil actually my
partner Shamir was on the board of Mobil
and uh when they uh and most of the
people at Mobi in the R&D came from A2
unit and they have a very had amazing
capacity to to uh find a solution for
the autonomous drive to develop a
solution to provide an automous driving
solution for the car industry so the
main uh breakthrough that came up with
mobilite that they were able when they
when with a camera very cheap camera
when were able to identify a pedestrian
that to avoid a collision uh you got the
alert and now we have a solution that
enables to control the car to avoid the
Collision Collision that's something
that is really disruptive and that's why
eventually Intel bought the company at
the time for 2020 billion and we think
that there are a lot of Technology
coming from the military that have a
very big impact Mobil just to
illustrate uh when they start using that
for the car leading insurance company in
Israel offered a subsidized solution to
their clients because it reduced by
40% the rate of fatal
accident wow
yeah incredible what does that what does
this mean the you know higher level this
the integration of private sector um you
know public sector government military
in the context of the startup
Nation think the key success of the
high-tech industry is that they are uh
they are really financed by the private
sector if you look at the Venture
industry you don't have governmental
money the government has a limited role
just it's indirect uh they favor
immigration and yeah uh they favor uh
R&D expenditure but they are not an
equity holder in the company and that's
enable the private sector to move much
faster especially in the ittech sector
that is a very Dynamic sector in places
like uh France for example you have uh a
lot of government funding where they
have Equity through Vehicles such as a
KES Depot or the B small these are this
is not the case in Israel you have 380
funds in Israel last year they invest1
17 billion in the Hightech industry and
that's how the Hightech industry has
been growing so fast when I started my
first Venture Fund in 93 we were three
Venture funds now we are 380 so and the
there is more than 100 unicorn in the
Israeli Hightech industry which is more
unicorn than all the EU put together so
wow industry has been moving very very
fast and this is obviously thanks to
this funding that we got mostly from the
US but also a lot from Europe and even
China incredible just incredible Edward
thank you so much for for this time and
for your um contribution to both in
general the startup ecosystem but also
specifically during during the war
you're obviously touching multiple
aspects from the te from the
technological aspects but but in the
communication and your thought
leadership and perspective to the social
impact that the that these companies
you've mentioned are doing and your
involvement there so thank you for
joining me and for taking the time I I
really really appreciate it and um and
I'm wishing you uh first of all your
your your son to be healthy and to be
safe thank you and for the rest of the
family and for all of us and um you know
I'm particularly inspired by you know
the the notion of everything that we
talked about really speaks to you know
the United n the United of of our
country and and the fact of how how
integrated all of these aspects are
together
to our existence and proliferation and
and continuously moving forward so I
appreciate it very much and um stay safe
thank you so much thank you for your
[Laughter]
effort